first of all I I this is this classes
the is called the industrialist ulema
it's all about disruption of legacy
industry's legacy business models
because of digital technology and I
appreciate you're really taking this
seriously because you're using a
blackberry right now so I thank you for
thank you for really underscoring
everything else is just a toy do you
want to explain the BlackBerry situation
that you have you know in all
seriousness its we just completed a
fairly sizable deal and in the middle of
it I didn't want to you don't like your
emails and model to change well guys you
go to China a lot there's totally hear
you okay so so that's what happens you
know when you're doing three and half
billion dollar acquisitions I guess
right and I've got an endorsement deal
okay that's good it's on brand it's good
yeah what do you want to sort of set
things up around what's the state of
legendary today given that deal that you
just did I mean that's pretty breaking
news here yeah so we did a deal with
Wanda from from China and I've been very
friendly with the chairman of Wanda for
the last two and a half three years and
he approached me last spring and we just
closed the deal recently I still run the
company and still have routing interest
in the company and although all those
things but for my chair it was a great
outcome for shareholders which is you
know part of my job if not all of my job
and when you look at the future of where
things are headed in terms of growth I
think China is probably the biggest
market in the world by 17 or 18 at the
latest our films had already done very
well in China our lytx group has been in
China for the last 18 months you know in
a pretty meaningful way and so for us it
made sense we've got a lot of different
sort of roads and choices but this made
sense for we actually had Tony Fadell
and as the second class I believe and
our third class and the way you were
describing offline around the kind of
control that you have of running the
it's all the creative control you are
sort of the nest of of one that I guess
yeah I mean it's early dance but it was
an attempted analogy why okay right on
so why don't we why don't we step back
and could you describe the state of the
media industry is obviously too broad of
a concept there's there's too many
different things going on but if we just
zoomed into film and an theatrical kind
of entertainment and television media
you have it maybe you could kind of give
us a little bit of a backdrop of like
you're in the center of Hollywood what
is the state of the world today in the
media industry well I think the clap not
you're at Stanford so I'm not surprised
by this but some really smart and
important points were made around the
room number one this is on the
theatrical side is becoming a
winner-takes-all business so the the
films that are breaking out are doing
better than ever and films that come out
even if they have a star even if they
have a lot of money behind them that's
not a shield against going to almost
zero and that that is a very very
different experience than when I first
started in this business in 2004 the
second thing my own personal opinion
because people will talk about the fact
that the films aren't quite as good and
so forth you know I grew I graduated
from high school in 1988 there were some
pretty bad movies in the eighties I
don't think they have it we have a
patent today or yesterday I'm on that
but it is the choices one of the things
I had our analytics group do was that
you know there's there's tracking
there's Nielsen ratings what I wanted to
know is in your waking addressable in
your and your time awake that is
addressable for consuming media how are
you spending that time where are those
points that are eroding for us that
didn't exist before where there is
snapchat whether it is YouTube somebody
sends you a link to an article and it
links to three other things all those
little things add up to less time and
there are high-class choices when you
talk about television I think we're in a
golden age of television we have a you
know a nice and robust television biz
and it used to be that television was
sort of like movie Jail you're a writer
actor or director and things were going
so well or you'd be that's all gone now
you have the most creative people in the
world crossing over back and forth of
incredibly compelling television
You certainly have new models with
people binging on it and so forth so on
a Friday night I don't think it's just
what movies are going head-to-head
what's a near Netflix queue you know
what what are the other quality forms of
entertainment that perhaps have a lower
barrier to entry meaning I got to get in
a car and drive somewhere and at
appointed time you know those are all
pretty big barriers so that's a little
bit of how we think about you know
what's going through consumers minds and
and Goodenough is certainly not good
enough anymore it kind of has to be
great and somebody had mentioned about
franchises which i think is hollywood's
second favorite f-word and it's an
interesting thing because while we're
flooded with that we certainly do that
at legendary some of the things that you
see breakout whether it's Deadpool which
is the biggest surprise of my career you
know being around this and our hard
r-rated film like Deadpool and I think
it's awesome and and really rooted for
it or guardians the galaxy you know they
did a great job with that but things
that are completely different you know
are doing well and at the same time
people want to see the franchise's that
they know and love and we're gonna talk
a lot about sort of Legendary's business
model and and kind of evolution going in
the future obviously because of the
blockbuster successes you guys have had
with Dark Knight and Jurassic world and
those kinds of movies I want to be clear
about one thing you said the movie
business is becoming more and more
winner-takes-all is that because of the
amount of choices people have and and so
the quality has to increase and so the
movies get better and that then creates
a winner-take-all environment or like
what what about the past five or 10
years has created winner-take-all
scenarios for the movie business just
we're super clear on the landscape
for you know my own personal opinion
it's a couple of things it is the
quality of choice I also think we're
becoming a swipe left swipe right
society in which we decide in mass
something is worth my time and I should
go see it and want to be a part of it or
it's not we are fortunate enough to have
Straight Outta Compton this summer
become a big hit for us even in places
that may be and in demographics that you
wouldn't have thought would be excited
about the movie and and people just
decided through social media and other
things that it was it was worth seeing I
also think that the winner-take-all
mentality is just that there's no slow
build anymore
mmm-hmm you go back just for fun and
look at how Titanic performed I mean it
came out to a modest I think it was like
a 14 million dollar opening and played
for months that and Maya that'll never
happen again ever for a number of
different reasons but there's there's
not a lot of big multiples against
opening weekend's we've seen that
squeeze down because there are so many
other choices you're now also seeing
movies open in February in March that
are hundred and fifty million dollar
movies which never happened before one
of the things legendary is known for is
your data analytics and how you look at
markets and trying to attract audiences
to the content one of the comments that
got raised during the class was the role
of kind of art versus business and how
is that changing Hollywood and
specifically how is data and information
changing how Hollywood does business
well a couple things first of all our
analytics group and team they're mostly
they're from Harvard and MIT and they
sit in Boston and I told them the first
time that I ever see you sitting in
Hollywood wearing a beret sipping a
latte and reading a script you're all
fired
and I'm in trouble we wanted it to be
complete separation of church and state
in terms of the creative side they have
absolutely nothing to do with it zero
we're not going to tell Chris Nolan what
to do in the third act of its that's not
going to happen so the reason that
we originally went into this is I felt
the advertising spend which I didn't
hear anybody talk about but that's the
part to me that it's not sustainable I
don't know if you know how much money we
spend on advertising but it's not a
great model at all what's the scale were
talking one hundred and two hundred and
twenty two hundred and forty million
dollars worldwide you know on
advertising for a film for a film for a
big film so that's that's a lot of money
what's not sustainable about that is
spraying it all over the place and
spending as much money on people who you
know aren't gonna come or folks that you
know you're advertising Dark Knight and
you're telling a fifteen-year-old who's
wearing a Dark Knight t-shirt please
come see my movie over and over that's
not very efficient either hmm
so put the analytics group together to
talk about people that were persuadable
and the first directive was very simple
I want to cut our ad spend by 15% and I
want to be no less effective we went
live on Godzilla that was the first time
we ever actually swallowed hard and did
it we cut our ad spend and tracking had
us opening at sixty million dollars and
we opened at ninety four so that that
was a good start and it has had a
material impact for us were you ever
able to actually track the people that
you advertise and did they buy tickets
yes we we were very calculated about it
and almost like a business case study
because if you don't test city to city
and it just well you has had a great
trailers right and and Warner Brothers
did an amazing job certainly on the ad
campaign what's happened since then is
it helps us to find audiences on
television and launch shows we've been
successful with that and over the last
year or so we were approached by some
very large companies and asked if they
could license our platform so it's
turned into a very robust business for
us do you see a future where that in
itself becomes its own business model
out of legendary are you kind of doing
that as a hobby right now
well it's inside you know
of what Wanda bought right and you know
we've been going the the two areas we
wanted to expand into was China which
which we've done pretty successfully not
only with Wanda some other big partners
trying to be early on consumer behavior
patterns and analytics there and the
second thing is making sure that we had
great core expertise around mobile and
and what that interaction looks like
from theirs on the data theme there's
clearly a trend or at least there's a
lot of noise about Netflix and how they
use data to target what kinds of shows
they should be green-lighting and buying
a do you how real do you think that is
of a trend do you think that that sort
of is instructive to the future of of
what kind of media gets created not
necessarily what shows up in the third
act of the film but do you breathe
certain kinds of TV shows or certain
kinds of movies yeah look Netflix is
extraordinarily successful and Ted
strandos who's down running content in
LA for Netflix does an incredible job I
think what it can potentially be our
guideposts you know to concept test and
whether it's stars or questions that you
want to ask I certainly think that can
be interesting we we tested Godzilla
versus King Kong because I was excited
about it and it turned out people
overwhelmingly thought that that was a
cool thing so we concept text like we
just don't before you spend 100 million
in a million and making a film yeah yeah
so Netflix you know they have a formula
and it seems to work for him
how do you spend your time and how do
you manage now a different type of
organizations as you've added new types
of businesses new people you support etc
this has become pretty complex what does
that impact to you as the CEO well it's
the mandate that I put forth four or
five years ago was we have to diversify
because simply being in the hip business
and we make five six movies a year not
20 or 25 like a like a movie studio so
you've got to have a great batting
average so we went into television we
went into analytics both
to take care of our margins on the spend
side on our advertising which again has
had a big difference for us we have a
pretty big digital presence we own
Nerdist we bought Smart Girls Amy
Poehler's company geek and sundry so
we've got a fairly decent-sized digital
footprint and are launching an S pod
model that were pretty interested in so
it was about diversification and
certainly making sure a number of years
ago before it was fashionable to have a
real hold in China and to you know learn
and make mistakes and tried to try to be
good partners in that corner of the
world and in terms of my own time it's
it's split between the creative process
and being very involved in our in our
movies trying to look around corners and
see what is the next version of
analytics and you know you talked a lot
about disruption and the only thing that
I know is if you if you stand on the
railroad tracks hoping the trains not
going to hit you it's going to hit you
so we're constantly asking ourselves
what does it look like when day and date
happens right that that's going to be a
pretty big shift when consumers are
offered offered that package I would
also say that for all the choices the
mentioned cat videos and so forth
I still believe in high quality long
term own ownership of content I believe
forever that's going to be an
extraordinarily important thing I
believe it in sports and I certainly
believe it across movies television and
digital there is a scarcity that I would
not underestimate talent is scarce
whether you're you know a great
filmmaker an actor an artist and we all
see it we all recognize it and I I don't
think that that is going to get wider
and so that's something that I think you
know Studios will have to organize
themselves around that principle is it's
a pretty closed ecosystem
but you're also not going to be able to
sustain the massive overhead and and
spending patterns that are there today
so before before you came on we were
talking about how distribution has
increased and I I would say just to
characterize that we've moved from a
model where you your distribution was
you know VHS or DVD in in physical
stores you had movie theaters and you
had a few you know cable networks and
and broadcasting channels so now you
have Netflix and Facebook and and
YouTube and snapchat and Instagram and
there's you know maybe a you know order
of magnitude increase in actual end
points and there's probably an order
magnitude increase in people that are at
the end of those delivery channels ie
the internet so for you and legendary
and then I'd like to kind of maybe
brought it up to you know let's say your
Warner Brothers or your your Sony how
does that impact the sort of overall
strategy does that does that mean you
move even more into the blockbuster
approach because again that choice means
that highest quality contrarians or do
you move more toward I need now 50
products to reach all the different sort
of variants of how people are going to
want to consume media and then if it's
the latter how do you actually monetize
that well the the way that we look at it
is there's sort of two categories of
films that we'll be making in the future
branded blockbusters or we hope they're
blockbusters but branded large tentpole
films or smaller containable targeted
films you know 42 is an example of that
straight out of Compton hangover we made
a movie called Krampus this Christmas I
don't know if any of you saw it but it
was we made it for nine million dollars
and we spent a third of what you would
normally spend on advertising to put it
out on 3000 screens and it turned out to
be a very nice hit for us we did just
under 70 million dollars and from a
stand a you know a business case
standpoint of allocating the right
capital being very targeted and using
but you still made how much of that
money was made theatrically in theatres
what I just named was only
the theatrical portion right so it'll be
out would that work the same way in a
day and date model where you don't have
all of the the sort of guaranteed access
at the theaters I believe first of all
it's inevitable and second of all I
think it'll broaden audiences the price
points have to be right the offerings
have to be right it's obviously going to
have a huge impact on the revenue
streams of the movie business but I also
think the amount of money that we spend
what used to be prints in physical
distribution and physical DVDs there's a
lot of friction points there the day and
day and digital will also help right now
you just have to be very responsible
about the way you're spending money so
if you're a bigger studio with a bigger
cost structure and you're entering this
new world do you have to lower your cost
structure including individual films and
marketing or do you need more products
across all the digital channels this is
a revenue growth mode or a sort of
lowering you know the cost to make media
III think it's to me it's a couple
things it's to ask yourself what kind of
organization are you gonna be right if
you've got thousands of employees
massive physical space the one place we
don't really shoot is in Los Angeles
it's just cost prohibitive so these
massive lots and and so forth that are
very expensive and so I think what you
have to ask yourself is what is your
core competency what is it going to be
going forward what can and can't you
defend and I think from a cost structure
standpoint I would stand back and say
we're gonna have to make some very tough
choices once you've gotten that under
control then I would look at what your
advantages are to making content and
filling those different pipelines I'm a
big personal investor behind both
virtual and augmented reality in with
magic leap down in Florida and the
oculus guys who did a great job and are
now part of Facebook that's I personally
don't think the tip of the spear there
is watching our movies in VR I don't
think that's that compelling the both in
terms of the time spent and artists will
come
with a way to give you you know a
different experience in a different
journey and that'll that'll shake out
and have a revenue model but I think
there's a lot of people in Hollywood
that are looking at that is oh that's
another stream and I just I think it's
going to shake out a little differently
if you look at how the younger
generation consumes media so we've got a
roomful of people in their 20s and 30s
you know do you see them going to fewer
movies in the future do you see them you
know not spending as much time as
previous generations have and how does
that impact the type of content that you
create well I would say I'm still a big
believer in going to the movies somebody
mentioned IMAX it's a great experience
watching a comedy with a crowd is
different than watching it at home even
with a few people watching a massive
blockbuster you know seeing Avatar which
Jim did a great job in that film of
giving you a reason to go so I still
think that that's part of our cultural
fabric and I don't think they're closing
up anytime soon I do think people are
going to be more and more discerning and
I think we're seeing that certainly in
North America the patterns we're seeing
in China are different there you're
seeing an expansion of middle class
seeing people enjoying going to
state-of-the-art movie theaters which
they've built all brand new stuff so
that's been interesting to watch but you
know and how it impacts us in the future
is really what I just talked about that
you know there be it needs to be so
compelling and great that you have to go
see it in that format or you should or
contained enough that however you choose
to do it you know that it's it's
fiscally responsible um Steve Jobs had
this classic line which was sort of
Hollywood doesn't understand so looking
valley Silicon Valley doesn't understand
Hollywood I'm sure was more element than
what I just said but the the the idea
was you know these are these are two
worlds that have never really been able
to partner very effectively but
certainly with iTunes and with Netflix
and with Facebook that has begun to
change what is the current sort of state
of thinking from from a Hollywood's
perspective of Silicon Valley being you
bridge both worlds
but let's say you weren't as sort of
sort of in between both worlds as much
what is the sort of state of thing is it
that that Netflix and Facebook begins to
take all of the leftover margin at the
platform level is that that they come in
and and create all the content and and
leave very little money for anybody else
is it that they end up moving eyeballs
into completely different you know
behaviors what what what is the
viewpoint right now I think it's a
mixture of fear and opportunity right
the fear from both directions is I think
those that on the platform realize that
professionally made content at the
highest levels is important and not
fungible and you're seeing that with the
decision points whether it's Netflix or
Apple are making by saying we've got to
be in the original content business you
know HBO made that decision smartly 15
years ago
and I think the fear side of it on both
ends is you know the tech companies have
bigger market caps right you're not
gonna push anybody around and and I
think that traditionally in maybe
Hollywood had been maybe the attitude
we're gonna wag a finger and you know
bully people and that that's not
happening up here so I really hope
things get bridged because it's
counterproductive and calories wasted
not to and I really think there are ways
to work you know smarter if you look at
what happened in the music business 14
15 years ago where you know the music
companies decided the way to respond the
Napster was to quote sue it back to the
Sun at Stone Age or whatever they used
to say you know and then they allow
Apple to come in and build the iTunes
platform that that's probably not
highest and best outcome if you're the
one sitting on the content do you
perceive there to be any risk that that
these technology platforms though can
can move the eyeballs and attention
completely away from traditional content
I mean your as an investor in magically
burrow oculus those platforms might not
make as much sense for linear
entertainment
and we might get the same sort of
entertainment value out of new forms of
content ie or thus being a risk to
traditional sort of the traditional DNA
of Hollywood is that is that a material
risk is that something that we think
about I think that VR and AR are the
first completely new experiences that
I'm aware of because they're everything
else whether it was VHS to DVD or
high-definition it's all I mean better
pictures right sharper pictures better
sound but VR AR is a completely
different experience so as we talked
about a little earlier anything that's
gonna erode from your time and attention
is a threat so you know that's why we
hedge and try to be in that business I
don't think anybody's figure out exactly
what the model is going to be yet we
have a lab on the 12th floor of our of
our building where we have very smart
creative amazing people coming in every
day and we wanted to have a place where
they could experiment and say I don't
know play around with it I'm sure you'll
come up with something but there's no
question it's a threat what what's your
I guess best hunch of what that content
type looks like in the future is it more
than just akin to video games or what
best I can tell and I certainly you know
it's interesting when YouTube you know
when people first started passing around
videos and saying you got to see this
right I think on VR the first couple of
viral things that are three four or five
minutes long and make you feel make you
feel something right and also I think
the social component is huge because
anything that we consume in discrete
packets is never as exciting is some
communal experience the experience
you're having now notwithstanding but I
think that the first time it's something
like that breaks through and passed
around and people then see what the
possibilities are
all those little movements need to
happen then all the creative people that
say yeah I should spend cycles in this I
should spend money on this can see
we're saying I should pay it and and all
those little movements that all of a
sudden add up to it's now a thing again
I think that's inevitable but that's
what I think the first couple of
movements look like and then I think
it's certainly there'll be video games
on it but I think the quantum leap
happens when we can go in the matrix
whatever together and kind of look
around and have a shared experience cool
all right Thomas all thank you very much